so tonight ahead of screening for the
new Adam Sandler drew Barrymore film
blended before it started my buddy and I
went over to the theater manager and
were like hey is it possible that we can
maybe just like sit in the back of
Godzilla right before it starts right
before our screening we just want to see
the interstellar trailer please and he
was like sure go ahead that's not a
problem
two things kick-ass theater manager you
rock man thank you and the other one is
finally a trailer that's awesome that
doesn't spoil everything that makes me
excited for the movie without giving
away a bunch of plot details and
actually makes me pumped for the film
and it looks awesome and I'm so happy
about that thank you Christopher Nolan
Warner Brothers Paramount Pictures and
whoever edited this trailer for actually
make me a trailer that does all those
things without spoiling every single
awesome part of the movie thank you it
looks good interstellar is my most
anticipated film for this year it is
directed by Christopher Nolan who in my
mind has yet to make a bad film it stars
Matthew McConaughey who has turned his
entire career around and still had the
balls to accept his Oscar by going
alright alright alright how awesome was
that by the way no one ever talks about
that that was so awesome that he
actually did that in this trailer we get
a little bit of the plot we actually
find out something about the plot
because on IMDB it actually says the
plot is unknown at this time how awesome
is that my most anticipated film of the
year the plot is unknown at this time
the trailer basically hints that mankind
is losing a lot of its resources
including its food and one of the most
profitable and required resources is
corn and they're trying to figure out a
way to keep it together I think like
that's what I love about I don't really
know for sure but it seems that new
technology is starting to surface and
the idea of interstellar voyage is on
these people's minds as a possibility
for a way to fix some of the problems
they're having on earth so Matthew
McConaughey has to leave his family
behind and travel on this voyage we see
one shot of Anne Hathaway in the ship we
see some really crazy dis acid trip
space imagery that looks incredible and
I'm really excited about that because
when I heard about this movie I was like
is this about the researching of
interstellar voyage and learning about
it or are we actually gonna go on one
we're going on one and I'm very excited
about that
and I love what they're doing with these
trailers the first teaser trailer just
gave us a few images from the film and
gave you a general vibe of what it was
sort of about this full trailer actually
does tell you more about what it's about
and still just shows you some awesome
imagery I'm already excited for it's
like the filmmakers know that and they
are trying to do their best to withhold
that because guess what showing
everything in your movies trailer
doesn't always guarantee that you're
going to make a lot of money I cannot
wait for November to see interstellar
what do you guys think of this new
trailer have you seen it because it
isn't available online yet that's why I
asked the manager I was like can we
please sneak into Godzilla please I just
watch the interstellar trailer and he
was like cool you're cool dude greatest
manager ever thank you sir
let me know what you thought of it below
if you did see it tonight with Godzilla
and as always guys thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck Munoz